in previous videos we talk about gdp as
the market value of final goods and
services produced in a country in a
given time period let's say in a given
year and we gave the example of
producing genes where maybe the farmer
helps produce the cotton and then the
thread maker takes that cotton and makes
thread and then the fabric maker takes
the the thread and makes fabric and then
the gene maker takes the fabric and
produces genes and so and then the
market value of those genes was 50
and so assuming all of this happened in
one year in the time period that we're
measuring gdp for then we would just
count the fifty dollars if we're looking
at the final market value or the market
value of final goods and services you
would say the gdp for at least for this
component of the gdp
from these genes is 50
but i do want to clarify that there are
multiple ways that you can measure gdp
and you could even think about it from a
value added
value added approach but the key idea is
no matter how you measure it you should
get to the same value
so let's think about the various actors
here and what their value add was
so first let's think about the farmer
right over here
so this is the farmer
my not so elegantly drawn rectangle
around what he's doing so the farmer's
value add
value
add is what
well before you just had some dirt and
and things and so maybe you could say
that the market value was zero and then
he's able to produce something or she's
able to produce something that now has a
market value of ten dollars so their
value add is
ten dollars
now from there the cotton goes to the
thread maker
the thread maker
they
take that ten dollar cotton so this is
thread
maker
they take the ten dollar cotton and are
able to produce twenty dollars worth of
thread what is their value add
value
add here
well they took something worth ten
dollars and they were able to do
something to it to make it work worth
twenty dollars so their value add is now
another ten dollars
and then this is the thread maker and
then from there it goes to the fabric
maker
the fabric maker and i think you see
where this is going the fabric maker is
this part
of our process
fabric
maker
and their value add is what pause this
video and think about it
well they take something worth 20 and
they were able to create it they're able
to turn into something that has a market
value of 30 so their value add is also
and then last but not least you have the
gene company
so the gene manufacturer
i'll call them the gene producer
the gene
producer
they take something that has a market
value of 30
and they're able to sell it for 50
so their value add
value add here
if you take something from 30 and you
make it worth 50 then you've added 20
dollars of value
and so the value added approach to gdp
will just sum up these value ads so this
is going to be this 10
from the farmer plus the value add of
the thread maker plus
ten dollars from the thread maker
plus ten dollars
plus ten dollars from
the fabric maker
plus twenty dollars
plus twenty dollars from the gene maker
and what will that all add up to
well that's all going to add up to ten
plus ten is twenty plus ten is thirty
plus twenty is fifty dollars and lucky
for us that has added up to the same
amount as we had before where we just
looked at the market value of the final
goods and services
now one benefit of the value added
approach is that real supply chains are
quite complex and things might be going
from one country to another they might
as we've talked about in another video
the year might end right over here and
so when something is made in china and
there's value value-add in china but
then it's shipped to the u.s and some
value add is placed on it and then
shipped back to china or mexico
you have to be careful to only count the
value add in the country for which you
are measuring the gdp so that's one
useful way of or one useful reason or
one way in which the value added
approach might be useful the key idea
though is that you're getting to the
same value you should get to the same
value as the market value of the final
goods and services produced in a given
time period